>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Georgette Dorn:
Good afternoon,
my name is Georgette
Dorn and I'm the director
of the Spanish Division
Library of Congress.
I want to welcome all
of you to this library
that has the largest
collection on Spain
in the United States,
outside of Spain.
And in addition to about
three or four million books
about Spain and Latin America,
we also have 40 million other
items among Ridgefair [assumed
spelling], lots of
motion pictures.
So it's a great [inaudible]
introduce now
that the Hardmon [assumed
spelling] and Paris
who will introduce our
speaker, thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Juan Manuel Perez:
Ah, good morning.
My name is Juan Manuel Perez
and I'm a reference specialist
in the Hispanic division.
And it is a great
pleasure to me to introduce
to you Fernando Ramos
whom I have known
for the past six months.
He has been coming
to the division,
to the Hispanic division
every single day
for the last six months from
about 9:30 to about five every.
He's currently working
as a visiting researcher
at Georgetown University in
Washington D.C. From 2010
to 2017 he was assistant
professor at the Institute
for Communication
in Media Sciences.
At the Leipzig University
in Germany
where he co-directed the
research project Cinefilia
[assumed spelling] under the
dictatorship film culture
between 1955 and 1975 in Spain
and a German Democratic
Republic.
Apart from the Leipzig,
he has also taught
at the [foreign language
spoken],
University of Valencia [assumed
spelling] and the University
of Brannon [assumed spelling].
For the academic year 2015-2016
he was a research fellow
at the [inaudible] in Madrid.
His main research fields
are in film culture,
culture of history, [inaudible]
theory and cultural studies.
He has been writing books and
has produced numerous articles
in many different academic
journals such as The Journal
of Spanish Cultural Studies,
The Historical Journal of Film,
Radio and Television,
Communication of Society
or the Hispanic Research
Council.
I mean Hispanic Research
Journal.
And just in about 10 days
he will start a new position
at the [inaudible]
University in Madrid.
So without further ado, I would
like to introduce commander
oh, before I forget.
Please turn your
phones to silent
or turn them off, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Fernando Ramos: Well thank
you for the kind introduction.
It is a pleasure and
privilege to be here.
I'm especially happy to invited
by the Motion Picture Broadcast
and Recorded Sound Division
and also first of the
by the Hispanic Division
of the Library of Congress.
Thank you very much also to the
staff at the Hispanic Division,
especially to Georgette, Juan
Manuel and Catalina who had help
to make this talk possible.
So, so let me start with an
example you may already know.
I'm going to show you a
little scene from the film
from the 1940's its
"Skilda [assumed spelling],"
film by Sauls Vidir
[assumed spelling].
Let me talk a little
bit over it.
That was a film
where [inaudible] directed
Charles Vidir [assumed spelling]
from 1946.
In it Rita Hayworth
[assumed spelling],
the protagonist sings
[inaudible] while she takes off
her gloves and throws them
white sexy in the audience.
[ Background Sounds ]
[ Music ]
Wow, that's.
[ Background Sounds ]
So, so just after that
she's pushed off the stage
and she's escorted
out of the room.
And this story just goes on.
You may know it.
This is a film noir.
However members of the Spanish
audiences watching this film
as it premiered in 1947 seem
to have had a very
different impression of it.
Apparently they thought
that the singing
and the taking off the gloves
were just the beginning
of something more,
something more interesting.
Was the beginning
of a strip tease
and that more sensual images,
those show when Rita Hayworth
[assumed spelling] naked have
been cut off the national
version of the movie.
That of course has
never been the case.
It was impossible for
our Hollywood Studio film
from the 1940's to such, to
show such explicit nudity.
However in the next month some
retouched images were sold
in some Spanish cities
showing bodies of naked women
with a face of Hayworth
[assumed spelling] on them.
They were presented as the
copies of this lost scene.
So that of course is a fan
anecdote, but I think also
that this very telling example
that helps us illuminate
a certain aspect
of Spanish film culture under
Francoism [assumed spelling].
This is this case of social
pathology in the words
of Herman Goburn
[assumed spelling],
helps us understand
the long-term,
somehow dialectical effects of
censorship under dictatorship.
For this a story of Froy
vision [assumed spelling],
of censorship and
imperfect film consumption
of the misunderstandings due
to the vision access to films
or to an absolute lack of access
since the films were
banned altogether.
It is also a story of creativity
in which cinema and culture
and the culture generated
around it,
provided a large projection
screen for the anxieties
for the fears and
the hopes of millions
of movie goers under
dictatorship.
So this, my talk will
focus on these paradox
on the characteristic of a
rich a complex film culture
struggling with its
enormous limitations.
Although many of the aspects
I would talk about apply
to the whole dictatorship
from 1939 till 1975,
I will focus mainly on a
period of roughly 20 years
that stretches from
the beginning
of the 1950's till
the end of the 1960's.
This is an era of complex
transformation both
for Franco regime and
for the cinema history.
The dictatorship starts to leave
behind the totalitarian policies
of the 1940's and develops
towards a cruel authoritarian
dictatorship opening
up just slowly
to international developments.
And in cinema history,
this is the time where
and when television kicks in
and European/Latin
American new cinemas start
to question Hollywood dominance.
I will focus in the periods
until, I will focus first
on the period until the
late 1950's and I will try
to eliminate the historical
and political context
where this phenomena took place.
I will concentrate mainly on
the effects and censorship
of censorship sorry,
on popular forms
of cinema consumption spans
since the end of the Civil War.
My argument or my main
argument here is that apart
from the [inaudible] vision
of certain films or scenes,
censorship introduced through
the modification of the works,
an element of insecurity
and speculation
in the reception process
in the way films were
watched and understood.
In the second part of my talk, I
would like to concentrate mainly
on some phenomena
characteristics sorry,
of a later period and
other forms of consumption.
Specialized film culture was
gaining a strong foothold
in Spain during the 1960's.
The focus will lay
on the alternative
or alternatives articulated
through a [inaudible] firm
of film consumption or as I
call it films watched on paper.
These are examples I have
been gathering as part
of an ongoing research project,
Juan Manuel already mention.
A film, a research
project on film cultures
in dictatorial regimes,
I have been working
on for the last six years.
It's a project, comparative
project that focuses
on the emergence of cinematic
sub-cultures in both in Spain
and German Democratic Republic
during the 1950's and 1960's.
And I think this the
examples I'm going to talk
about now function in
my opinion are symptoms,
a symptoms like symptoms
of an illness and symptoms
of in this case of
two illnesses.
One political illness
like the dictatorship,
but sometimes also a symptoms
of a more benign illness,
which is this fascination,
this obsession to the point
of obsession for cinema.
So talking about the 1940's
and 1950's in Spain is focusing
on a golden age of cinema going.
Cinema was still seen under
the so under the introduction
of television at the
end of the 1950's,
as the main favorite
pastime for the majority
of the national population.
Firmly rooted as a
form of entertainment,
especially among the popular
cases, sorry, classes.
It was something you used
to do with your family,
but it was also a special form
of entertainment
for women and youth.
And it was like in other
European countries,
mainly an urban pastime.
Spectators in big and
richer cities where,
went more often to the movies.
For instance in 1948 each
citizen of Madrid went four
to five times to the movies.
Means almost once a week and she
or he had 117 theaters
to choose from.
So they could rely on a dense
network of film theaters.
Spend half of the late
40's, the highest number
of film theaters per
capita in whole Europe.
So cinema was a mass
phenomenon, a cultural practice
that was just everywhere.
A central part of everyday life.
As commanded by the film critic
Miguel Marias [assumed spelling]
and I quote: "It was the
cheapest and most popular form
of entertainment and recreation.
The fastest way to leave
and satisfy in social
and vital environment.
The shelter for couples escaping
the atmospheric [inaudible],
a spectacle for the
whole family."
End of quote.
So how does this situation
relate to censorship?
Censorship under
Francoism started
to be applied already during
the Spanish Civil War,
so before the regime
kicked in in 1939
and could survive
the dictator itself.
So existed until 1978.
In these 40 years censorship,
these positions could
obviously reflect the certain
transformation that ran parallel
to the power struggles
in the regime.
The fastest party
[inaudible], the Catholic Church
and the army, which were
the three main pillars
of the regime could
influence the evolution
of the national censorship
organs.
Roughly one can for instance
assert that's the fastest
principle of the [inaudible]
and military were more permanent
in the early years
where censorship focused
on implementation of
specific political world view.
While in the following
decades some of these
in these aspirations
were set aside
as Francoism partially reshaped
its iconological principles
around an ultra-conservative
national Catholicism.
In all 4 years films were censor
on both political
and moral principles.
There was thus a
transformation in time,
but it was also an
insecurity caused
by the different parties
involved in this process.
Far from being a monolithic
phenomenon following clear
rules, they control
exercise over the images
and sounds took place
in different forms
and was executed by
different actors.
Both the state and the
church were allowed
to impose their principles
through their own
censorship images,
but censorship included also
certain distribution companies
prone to make some
cuts in the films
as they believed this could
secure them better chances
by the censorship authorities.
Movie theaters, as well as
particular circumstances
in alternative projection
spaces,
such as film clubs
or church cinemas.
And third, a third point I
would also like to emphasize,
I think it's also essential
to consider the discretional
and arbitrary character
of national censorship.
While the state could implement
for the first time a code,
the censorship code in 1963.
So up until then
film censor had to,
censors had to act along a
loose pledge of allegiance
to the regime and
the Catholic Church.
And focus on such vague
attributes as morality,
good manners or decency.
This strange indefinable legal
frame influences not only the
work of filmmakers
for almost 25 years,
but also it also made it
position of distributers,
exhibitors and audiences very
difficult as this of victims
of this lack of coherence,
sorry.
In the criteria.
Audiences were in many
occasions unable to answer
such simple question
as how is the message
of the film being manipulated?
Is there, was there originally
a hidden [inaudible] I am now
missing or which part of the
original text has been cut out?
At this point it is clear that
I am not referring only to the,
to when I talking
about censorship,
I'm not only referring to
certain, the prohibition
of certain works of specific
scenes, which is a phenomenon
that has already been studied
and can be easily
understood along the emergent
of the legal frame.
I find more interesting to think
about its long-term consequences
in the field of film reception
about the censorship effects
on individual cinema goers.
Well it is relevant to
point out censorship meant
of course the prohibition
of certain works, but also
and this is an interesting
aspect in this case.
The editing of scenes
in a new way
or the modification
of its meaning.
When audio tracks
were changed in order
to transform the original
message of the film.
So that in for instance was of
international people titles was
for instance obliged
from 1941 till 1947
and lasted de facto until 1967.
A good example of this
practice can be found
in the final scene
of "Bicycle Thief."
The 1948 new realist masterpiece
by Victoria De Sica [assumed
spelling], which premiered
in Madrid in the 1950's
which was usually screened
at the national film clubs
throughout the decade.
Antonio who is the well the
main character in this film,
is a small worker in
post-World War II Rome
who is completely
dependable on his bicycle,
which had been stolen from him
at the beginning of the film.
He and his son Bruno try
in various occasions
to get it back.
In the last part of the
film Antonia even tries
to steal another
bicycle, but he's caught
and Bruno sees what
happens to his father.
So this is quite a hopeless
situation, very sad,
it's very bleak ending.
Too sad apparently for the
eyes of the Spanish censors
or for yeah or for their opinion
on the Spanish audiences.
So in the last scene as Antonia
and Bruno are walking hand
in hand and disappear
in the crowd,
a new voiceover was
added to the film.
So it provided a certain
comfort, but also oh sorry,
a Catholic reinterpretation
of the message of the film.
So let me show it to you.
Sorry for the quality of the
film, but you may have an idea.
Okay I'm going to introduce
what's what this voiceover's
now telling.
The morning, the new morning
seem full of anxieties
for this man, but he
wasn't alone anymore.
He hold Bruno's warm
little hand in his own hand
and his hand told
him about faith
and hope in a better world.
In a world where men
would understand them self
and love each other.
And achieve the generous
idea of Christian solidarity.
So that is the message
which was completely missing
from the original film.
[ Background Sounds ]
Well this wasn't an
exception of course.
Sometimes there were just
some words as for example
in "Casablanca" where the
main character Rick mentioned
that he had fought for
the Republic in Spain.
That was of course cut it off.
In all the cases it
went even farther.
In [inaudible] by
[inaudible] from 1965.
The film's distributers
added a prolog also in form
of the voiceover in order
to warn the audiences
about the revolutionary
character of this film.
"Mogambo" [assumed spelling]
by John Ford [assumed
spelling] was screened
in Madrid in the early 1950's.
However the film came with
a serious modification
of its original message
through dubbing of the dialog.
Apparently in this case it
was the distribution company
who was afraid of possible
conflicts with censorship.
So Grace Kelly and Donald Sinden
which are two of the protagonist
of the film, were originally
wife and husband in the film,
in the original version.
But they were transform
in sister
and brother through dubbing.
So instead of showing something
so morally wrong as adultery,
the film was now endorsing the
incest between the protagonists.
So similar effects can
be observed also in the
"Barefoot Contessa" by
Joseph Mankiewicz from 1954.
Well this and all the
practices however different
in their origins have
a similar effect.
Once known to introduce
an element of insecurity
in the reception based on a
possible shift of the meaning
or the message of the
original text of the work
as originally conceived.
The instability of
the texts censored
in such spectacular ways
provided also perfect basis
for the speculation
among the audiences.
In such cases it
seems to be impossible
to find a clear closed meaning
that could give the content
of the film a certain coherency.
Therefore the censorship
is reading
with exerting certain works.
Its long-term effects are to be
found in the gaze of an audience
that this causes, speculates,
supposes even imagines certain
original texts even in the cases
when the film they are watching
hasn't been censored at all.
So until now have been
referring mentally to the films,
but it this also interesting
to consider the way
audiences reflected
on their film watching
experiences.
So Loge Lecho Lavange [assumed
spelling] from NYE commented
on the research project and
popular audience response
to cinema in the early Franco
dictatorship and I quote,
"Almost all of our
interviewees were aware, sorry,
of the existence
of film censorship.
Since those scenes were often
met with boos and hisses,
several also said that the
censorship heightened desire
as you always imagine something
more exciting that what's,
that what had been cut.
Several talk of their
disappointment
on seeing certain films
and censor later."
End of quote.
This an important point for it
makes clear that film audiences
in the 1940's and 1950's
know when that films were,
knowing that the films they
were watching were censored,
were more active
than usually assumed.
The censored parts
which were often visible
since the image could
jump or briefly go blank.
Provided a gap in the text,
which the viewers could fill
in with their own imagination.
Reinforcing the distance between
the images on the screens
and the images in their heads.
So here's where the former
example of Gilda would fit in.
In this regard it is relevant
to highlight the importance
of American Hollywood
pictures in the country.
Spain represented in those years
the second highest [inaudible]
for Hollywood movies, which were
central in the local film diet
and also a canvas to
predict the [inaudible]
of a nation if you like.
America as seen through the
images of Hollywood, represented
and was read as stronghold for
cosmopolitanism, sophistication,
the femme fetal, sexiness,
the political divergence,
sorry and modernity.
Well for those things
and values lacking
in the local film culture.
In this regard and the
part from usual comments
on the immersive attraction
excerpted by these films,
there was also usually a
recognition of the capacity
to open up to all the realities.
These are some quotes
from the research project
already mentioned.
You enter the movie
theater and you start
to leave, to leave sorry.
All this made you
live something,
make you live something
you didn't have.
But I found especially
interesting this third one,
this idea of cinema's
a way of dreaming,
as a way of projecting yourself
into the movies so to speak.
Another variation of this motive
both emergent and projection
in the screen is provided
by the writer Derency
Moykes [assumed spelling],
a caton [phonetic]
writer who belonged
to Cinefa [assumed
spelling] generation
that could influence
the Spanish literature
in the following
decades and often go back
to cinematic memories looking
for inspiration and subjects.
Well first to our book
covers, the third one is
of course a movie, movie poster.
Apart from Mike's,
this generation included Juan
Marce [assumed spelling],
which is a representative
through the first book cover.
And Ricka Vilamatas [assumed
spelling] Per Inferer [assumed
spelling] even be [inaudible]
enough for x many of them.
Forming at these writers
started these, sorry,
their careers writing criticism
for specialized magazines.
Well Mike's in the first volume
of his autobiography mentions
the first Spanish screenings
of "Cat on a Hot Tin Roof."
A film by Richard Brooks from
1958, which is the film showed
at the right part of the screen.
Mike thought that explicit
homosexual elements
of this melodrama had been
cut out by the censors.
The local audiences,
victims of the nation
of Catholic censorship were not
allowed to watch or hear them
so it was his way of thinking.
This homosexual subtext
which was of course part
of the original playwright
by Tennessee Williams,
was however not really present
in the original version
of the film.
It would have been inconceivable
being the title was produced
under the conservative climate
of the U.S.A. in the 1950's
where film students were
still attached to the rules
of the production code
the from the 1930's
to the 1960's controlled
the possible moral
and ideological subversion
of studio productions, sorry.
So around 1960 I would
say or during the yeah,
in the late 1950's or 1960's
alternative specialized forms
of film consumption will or
would win momentum in Spain.
Sorry, well this wasn't used
to a Spanish phenomenon,
this was something which that
was happening other European
countries at the time.
In this sense, this social
pathology mention on the,
at the beginning of the
talk regarding the case
of Gilda would transform itself
around different
reception practices.
For instance in film clips
around another cultural
practices
like for instance the
[inaudible] and discussion
of film screen written
of specialized criticism
on around other references.
European cinema modernity was
starting to be in the center
of the discussions instead
of Hollywood cinema.
But it won't disappear,
the social pathology
won't disappear.
A new cinema increasingly
consumed as high culture
in spaces and rituals that
remind us of our religion,
could have its own forms
of speculation born
out of enthusiasm,
misinformation and censorship.
So the movie theater
was packed comment
for instance I was told
Torres [assumed spelling]
on a screening in the film
club from Madrid in 1963.
Torres [assumed spelling] was
a film critic at the time.
The film screened in this
occasion was a little a title
by the Shred This Altar Ingmar
Bergman [assumed spelling]
who was an apostle of
the modernity of new way
of making movies and
thinking about them.
Who was during those
years very admiring Spain,
but also rarely known.
Torres [assumed spelling]
continues his description
with the following words.
The lights went out,
the projection started
and a stony sorry, stony
silence settled in.
Nobody understood a
word from the dialogs,
but no one said a word.
No one commented the scenes as
if we were in a [inaudible] mess
and to some laughs
could be heard.
These were rapidly silenced
by the rest of the audience,
but someone kept
laughing causing a growing
public outrage.
Well the funny part
is the next one.
So it was only sometime later
that I watched this film
with subtitles, then
I understood
that Smiles Was Summer Night was
one of Bergman's best comedies
and that the ones laughing
in the movie theater were
the only Swedish people
or Swedish speaking
people in the room.
So this may be a very
striking example,
but was surely not
an exception in 1964
as the film club starting
importing new films
and the new censorship rules.
The titles included "The
Criminal" by Joseph Losey
of [inaudible] by Jean Luco
Dark [assumed spelling] as well
as the Polish film, "Like
Siberian Lady Macbeth"
by Fida [assumed spelling]
or "Posiac" [phonetic]
by [inaudible].
All these films circulated
through the film club
network in the next years.
However and considering
the experience described
by Torres [assumed spelling],
it's worth questioning how
these titles were received
or if they were even understood.
The bridges in the
French film were screened
in original versions
without subtitles.
"Siberian Lady Macbeth"
came with English subtitles.
"Posiac" [assumed spelling]
remind you was a Polish film
with French subtitles
and the part from "Smile
of the Summer Night" previously
mentioned in description
by Torres [assumed spelling],
another of Bergman's
[assumed spelling] film
"Summer Interlude" was also seen
in the Spanish film
clubs in a confusing way.
Both titles were shown
in original Swedish
version without subtitles.
So Bergman [assumed spelling]
in this case also symptomatic,
it talked [inaudible]
function as touched
on for different film
critical approaches
of the beginning of the 1960's.
Those were on one side.
A new criticism around new
[inaudible] interested in more
than this to persistent cinema.
And on the other side
the representatives
of the cultural establishment
who control some
of the old strongholds of
debate and we're still trying
to present a certain profile of
the Swedish author or director.
More defined the
message of his films
through the dubbing and editing.
So from the perspective
of the new critique
and especially among new
alternative magazines
such as [inaudible]
or [inaudible].
People would react in rage
against this interested
modification.
So [inaudible] who was a left
wing critic commented this
situation in article published
for the magazine [inaudible]
in 1963 with some irony.
He noted there is a
Bergman [assumed spelling]
Spanish style.
Where does this such, where does
such a phenomenon come from?
From where they say that
nothing has been cut off,
but it has been.
Why they say the Bergman
[assumed spelling] is a
religious film maker and
sometimes a Catholic one.
And to prove the point
dialogs are changed
and important parts just vanish.
So this curious to
see how the work
of international
well-known film makers
like Michelangelo Antione
[assumed spelling],
Ingmar Bergman [assumed
spelling],
Francois Duforg [assumed
spelling]
and Luco Dark [assumed
spelling],
et cetera et cetera et cetera.
Is thoroughly sorry analyzed in
the news, specialized magazines.
Even when most of these
films couldn't be seen
by the readers of
the publications.
This paradox doesn't escape the
authors writing for these film,
writing about these
filmmakers sorry.
In an anonymous text for
film [inaudible] published
in the 1959 and the
usual [inaudible] known.
Caulfield [assumed
spelling] [inaudible],
Ingmar Bergman [assumed
spelling]
or Robert Aldridge [assumed
spelling] are mentioned before
the author explains the maybe
so good as the book tells.
Maybe this opinion we may never
have the chance to verify it.
In these small specialized
publications the debate
benefited from a censorship
that was more permissive
with magazines than with the
films, which were supposed
to reach broader
audiences aware there
for consider more dangerous
in the eyes of the state.
Well we think to consider
censorship dispositions
as monolithic, in fact
they were also adaptable
or were continually been adopted
to the potential audiences both
in quantitative and also
in a qualitative way.
Specialized smaller groups
like for instance readers
of magazines, people at film
festivals and film clubs were
in fact much better off
than the mass audiences
in the commercial
movie theaters.
Beyond this confusion and these
cautions, once the effects
of this mixture of fascination
and censorship was the emergence
of a film culture which was more
focused on the written text,
a cinema on paper that
was particularly partially
accessible than in the
cinematographic text usually
missing, particularly for a vast
majority of spectators unable
to go abroad, visit film
festivals or enjoy the titles
in the most selected film clubs.
On the basis of these
differences debate was being
encouraged, that
was by necessity,
speculative [assumed
spelling] discussion more based
on the written word than on
the images interested not only
in recovering the fleeting
images in the movie's theater,
but also in drawing attention
at you those works this that due
to the censorship could not
have or could not be seen
on the national screens or
only in selected circles.
Noest Cocina [assumed spelling]
could complain it in a editorial
from 1967 where the Madison
[assumed spelling] looked back
at his work for almost
seven years and reflected
on the implications of hardness
spread discourse on films,
on the film criticism
on cultural life
which was becoming less
and less significant
for most of its readers.
For its references, the
references of the discourse,
had nothing to do
with the films they,
I mean the readers usually
watch in the theaters.
Jesus Cathia Luenas [assumed
spelling] who was one
of these bookish cinefiles
[assumes spelling] dependent
on the magazines who was student
of the state film schools in the
since the beginning of the
1960's and also contributed
to journals such as
Nuestrafine [assumed spelling],
commented his personal
experience in following terms.
Our cinematic education was more
based on books than on films.
I will give you very
graphic sample.
Back then Strohan [assumed
spelling] was my favorite
director, but I hadn't
seen any of his films.
My knowledge of his films was
limited to what I had read
on him and to this or over
him unto the scripts published
in Lavan Scenes Cinema [assumed
spelling], which I devoured.
This form of cultural
consumption,
reading films instead
of watching them,
was not only possible
through the reading
of international magazines,
Spanish most wrote on titles
like the aforementioned cinema,
Universitadio [assumed
spelling],
Film Medial [assumed spelling],
Nuestra Fina [assumed spelling]
or Cine Studio [assumed
spelling].
Those were all new
Madisons [assumed spelling]
who started their careers at
the beginning of the 1960's,
would quite often publish
scripts or transcriptions
for dialogs as well as the verse
forms of literary adaptations.
This [inaudible] didn't work
always without problems however.
The publication of scripts was
also censored so this happened
for instance as Nuestra Fine
[assumed spelling] planned
to publish the script of
Jewel a Jim [assumed spelling]
by Drufo [assumed spelling]
in 1962, which was banned
by the censorship based
on moral consideration.
So the lack of the direct
references could have very
picturesque effects even among
these selected more specialized
circles, which were
the come first
between a theoretical
discourse with certain level
of elaboration and the lack
of films was even bigger.
Just imagine the absurdity
of studying in Spain the work
of Doschenko [assumed spelling],
Eizenstein [assumed spelling]
or Digavert of said
Cadorsabra [assumed spelling].
We watched none of the
films of these guys
and we knew their
theories by heart.
It was complete nonsense
commented Sarah who was
at the time was teacher of
the, who was first student
and then teacher at the
Spanish film school at the end
of the 1950's and 1960's
as he was starting
his own film career.
He also added to that.
Occasionally that he also added
that and then it happened to me
that I watched Eisenston's
[assumed spelling] films
and I was completely
disappointed so.
So, well sometimes it's the
prohibited fruit is tastier
than the real one.
So the debate generated
in the magazines could be
reached certain points capable
of generating [inaudible]
and discussions,
but was also damaged
in its core.
It was a discourse without
references usually based
on versions that had to be
mutilated or [inaudible] up
and that couldn't disguise
the lack of knowledge
and basic information.
Even the good or the
history of study of the Fine
by Roman Gubern [assumed
spelling], which is one
of the first serious enterprises
of this kind in Spain
and which was republished
in 1969.
Even this book I say we
still find a lot of films
with that are wrongly summed up.
So it's clear that
they are writing
about films they have nevers
have the chance to see.
The reality was that despite
the bookish consumption I quote
for these or other
reasons this cinema fan
in Spain doesn't know the French
novel Bach [assumed spelling],
the British free cinema
the American new wave,
the renaissance of Italian
cinema, the new schools coming
from Poland or Czechoslovakia
[assumed spelling].
That is to say they do not
know the main movements,
the half shaped contemporary
cinema.
Lamented Garcia Duenos [assumed
spelling] in their article
for the magazine
[inaudible] in 1967.
In this regard Rosary
Squarner [assumed spelling]
who was a cinefa
[assumed spelling] member
of different film clubs
writer in magazines.
Even focus on this dialectical,
on this dialect dialectical
effect of the situation
and ask himself if the critical
activity during the 1960's
concentrated increasingly, an
increasingly smaller circles
and therefore quite different
from those early forms
of popular film consumption
already commented
at the beginning, was not
the consequence of the fact
that because there was no films,
we have to that invent
them in writing.
Without being aware of
it, a [inaudible] peril
of universe was being created.
The outcome of this
[inaudible] in a period
of cultural restrictions was
in many cases cinefas [assumed
spelling] without films,
cultivated without culture,
marked by a kind of knowledge
of free and by the will and
not the fact as commented
by his colleague Joels Oliver
[assumed spelling] while talking
about the way Roberto Rosalini
[assumed spelling] was unknown
by Spanish cinefile, in
Spanish cinefile quarters
up until the late 1960's.
So given our time constraints
I'm going to stop here.
I think I have already
prove my point.
In spite of the limitations due
to censorship, the modifications
of some of the great works
of international cinema
or the errors and
omissions in the discourses,
both film consumption and
specialized film culture enjoyed
up until the end of the
1960's, considerable vitality
and that reflect the
[inaudible] transformation
of the country and the media.
Some of this observation may
also apply to other countries.
Spain was truly not
the only place
where active censorship
words were doing their job
in the in this years.
But this particular case
presented an intense example
that served to illuminate the
cultural life of the country
for almost 20 years to show
that censorship usually goes
beyond the simple provision
that if all is activated
alternative forms of reception
which were surly no
intended in the first place.
And that spectators were
usually involved in forms
of decoding much more complex
and active as usually accepted.
And that apart from a
mere history of films,
film history can also provide
an interesting timely analysis
of some unexpected
corners of cultural life.
Thank you very much
for [inaudible].
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.